now there are three really important
things that you should know if you drink
a lot of tea now normally when you think
about tea you think about something
that's pretty healthy and um i mean it's
better than coffee right and people
drink a lot of tea in fact the great
majority of the planet drinks tea but
there are three things that are just
really important
to know if you are a tea drinker now
certain teas are high in something
called tannins now
especially if it's black tea
like english breakfast tea those teas
are really high in tannins
now green tea is very low in tannins but
when you're exposed to tannins there's a
couple things that happen number one
tannin tends to bind
or chelate
iron
okay
zinc
and
calcium so if you're drinking a lot of
black tea
you're binding up your iron your zinc
and your calcium and then you may start
experiencing symptoms of those minerals
but also tannins
block the absorption of
thymine b1 and b1 from my viewpoint is
one of the most important vitamins i've
done a lot of videos on b1 but if you're
deficient in b1
you're going to get anxiety you're going
to have nervous tension
when you go to sleep at night you might
have more vivid dreams or even
nightmares or restless leg syndrome but
b1 deficiencies relate to a lot of
problems with your nervous system and
since we're on the topic of b1
i think it's really important to
understand other things that can deplete
b1 as well let's go through the list
caffeine which by the way is in tea and
coffee coffee has tannins as well
sugar
refined grains
sulfites
alcohol
metformin
which can cause a symptom of lactic
acidosis which is kind of dangerous so
if you're on metformin you better be
taking more b1 as well as b12 because
both of those vitamins get depleted
all right raw fish can deplete you of b1
as in sushi antibiotics antacids
diuretics birth control pills
ssris as an anti-anxiety or
anti-depressive medication
seizure medication
human papillomavirus vaccines chlorine
from tap water
and if you chew beetle nut that will
also deplete b1 all right number two the
second problem with tea okay certain
teas are loaded with heavy metals okay
like aluminum lead
and arsenic now i will say that the
source of the tea really will tell you
if there's these heavy metals for
example if you get your tea from china
there's been an interesting study which
i'll put down below that shows that not
only does a lot of teas from china have
heavy metals but they're loaded with
pesticides one study showed 29 different
pesticides and most of them were illegal
so when you buy tea you really need to
know the source of where you get the tea
japan for example has a much higher
quality tea also one common toxin in tea
is fluoride okay so the soil which the
tea is grown on
really reflects what's going to be in
that tea
tea has to be grown in acidic soils so
in that environment a lot of things are
absorbed into that plant that can be not
just regular healthy minerals that you
need but actually toxic
metals so the source of the tea
matters don't go for the cheapest tea
find something that is
comes from a source that's very very
healthy
now number three
the tea bag itself some of these tea
bags are bleached with chlorine
pronounced
epichlorohydrin okay and this chemical
is actually a carcinogen so definitely
don't stop drinking tea just make sure
you imply four things with tea make sure
your tea is organic make sure if you
consume a lot of tea that you also take
b1 at the same time as well as taking
minerals okay because t will deplete b1
in minerals
and lastly you might want to buy tea
that it's kind of like a loose leaf that
is not in a bag or if you're getting
those little bags make sure the bags are
bleach free tea bags and i would make
sure that you research your teeth to
know where it comes from
the source matters so since you're on
the topic of tea
if you haven't seen my video on green
tea check that out i put it right here
you